roughly every year 360 000 tons of
fishing gear is lost in the water
even though they're abandoned they are
still catching animals and i was always
appalled that nobody was doing anything
about them
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is curt lieber i'm the president
and founder of ocean defenders alliance
we get volunteer divers to remove
abandoned commercial fishing gear so all
the nets traps and lines that are out
there that are still killing animals
that's what we focus on removing
typically in a year we will have 10 to
12 whale entanglements from this fishing
gear over the last four years
that number has climbed from 12
roughly to 72 so it's getting worse
our main focus are abandoned lobster
traps
these lobster traps and crab traps have
lines attached to them and the line has
a surface marker buoy that goes to the
surface and a boat comes along and cuts
that
or it gets moved around in the storms
and the fishermen can't find it they
don't leave them behind just for no good
reason
be prepared to move fast if i need to
push this off
our expeditions are pretty chaotic i'd
have to say we start out early in the
morning with usually six divers
it's really difficult to locate these
traps because obviously you can't see
through the water it's like a hunt and
peck kind of uh thing and it's not cost
effective but when you're talking about
life does it matter if it's cost
effective or not
not in my eyes i get them out to a site
we drop anchor
say they come across a trap they attach
a lift bag to it the lift bag then goes
to the surface
[Music]
with the trap attached to it and then we
put it on the hoist
clear
the oceans have been really decimated
over our lifetime i'm a fighter i will
go down fighting and most of my
volunteers feel the same way
i don't know if i'm making a big
difference in the overall scope of
worldwide problems you can only tackle
so much in your life and i'm doing what
i can personally
when you get down there and see the
impact that you're making locally
that's what keeps us going
you